ce qui s'est passé dans cette chambre d'hôtel
euh c'était une nuit de coupon et j'étais en
train de trampoliner ta femme
qui était l'homme mystère au téléphone euh
son nom était va te faire [ __ ] vraiment ouais il était
asiatique
ouais il neige un personnage qui est euh
sur papier pas vraiment
très  personnage sympathique dans le sens où
il est vous savez
qu'il est cynique il est euh
il ne se soucie pas vraiment de personne
qu'est-ce que c'est pour arrêter le saignement
et j'espère que la conversation mais euh il est
très drôle genre d'humour sec
son son son personnage a toujours été
euh
a toujours été comme ça depuis le début de la neige
que se passe-t-il les célébrités du réchauffement climatique
obtiennent un congrès sur le travail des seins
scolarisent à nouveau le chien
vous savez même vieux
ce ne serait pas des storyboards dans la mesure
où les storyboards seraient si
précis parce que vous pouvez
vous savez essayer  et gardez ça drôle
mais pour essayer de le garder un peu sérieux
aussi en même temps ne vous
méprenez pas c'est des vacances de rêve je veux dire
je charge en allant dans l'espace je rentre dans
la maison des écrous à sécurité maximale
sauvez la fille du président si elle n'est
pas déjà morte
dépassez tous les psychopathes qui viennent de se
réveiller je suis ravi que vous
pensiez à moi
êtes-vous toujours aussi odieux
non je profite juste du silence